Hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 21 of my 0 to 100 mil flipping
series. Today we are starting at about
25 mil, just over a third of the way
there. And we're going to hit up some
new items and let's see uh how much
progress we can make today. So we're
going to start again with another
samurai flip uh just because they have
been working quite well. Um so we kind
of are just going to guess the price
here. So about 299k and we're going to
do about 10 of these to begin with. Uh,
but we'll do a couple new items this
episode for sure. Next up, we are going
to do another samurai set. Not big
surprise to anyone. Um, and we're going
to do it. I'm going check the margin for
600k and we'll buy it for 335.
And let's see how much we can sell it
for.
326.
Don't think I'm going to do that. Um,
let's move on to the samurai gloves. Uh,
put an offer in and check what the
margin is there. uh we could not buy it.
So, it's a little bit more expensive. Uh
a little bit hard to know with these
items because I mean they're they're
obviously their medium price that's
automatically generated is not right. Um
so, you kind of have to just plop it in
there and wait for it to buy. Um I guess
it's somewhere between 500 600k maybe.
So, we just put an offer in for 350k.
Didn't end up buying it, but we'll just
see if we end up uh buying any of these.
Didn't end up checking it though. Okay,
so we're going to check the margin for
the Sarah Domen sword. I bought it for
1330K and we're selling it for $1279. Uh
it's actually not too bad. Uh we could
definitely just quickly flip eight of
these within an hour or so and it has a
50k margin each. So uh looking at about
400k or so. Okay, so we're going to put
an offer in for 1280k and 10 of them.
And yeah, we'll go get at least one more
item before we come back. Okay, so the
samurai boots actually have a pretty
decent margin on them. So we'll go do
that instead. We were going to try fewer
ornament kit, but uh didn't end up
working out. Okay, so we are back. Um
we're just here to readjust the prices
and we do have a couple completed offers
as well. Um so the Seridom swords we
ended up getting a 25k margin on and
eight of those gives us about 200k which
is not too bad. Uh the samurai greaves
we actually got 28k
margin on each one. Five of those gives
us 1,040k so just over 1 mil. Uh, mind
you, we did have two. Actually, no, we
didn't check the margin for that one. We
just guessed it. Uh, so that's pretty
awesome. Got over a mill just from that
one flip. And, uh, I think we're going
to pull out the Greaves because they
have stopped selling. U, we'll calculate
that margin later cuz we just do not
feel like doing that now. Uh, so we're
going to go ahead and put the samurai
greaves in for a different price, lower
it just a little bit, and I'll come back
with uh when the rest of items have
sold. Okay, we are back. Um, these
things are taking so [__] long to
sell. So, we are just going to And we
have like 35 mil in our inventory. I
don't know what we're doing. So, we're
going to go pick a couple items quickly
here. And uh hopefully by the time the
next set of items sells, these will
finally have sold. Okay, so we're
actually going to check the margin on
the new free-to-play boss item, the Hill
Giant Club. No idea how much this item
costs. Um but we bought it for 2.3
mil pretty much. And we'll see what we
can sell it for. Put it in for 1 mil.
and we sold it for 2110.
Um, it's about a
170k margin, which is very good
considering this item is actually traded
quite a lot. Now, it's not a very stable
item, and I did do this when the fire
tome came out and I lost a bunch of
money,
but
um, we'll do it for the video. So, we'll
put an offer in for seven or eight, and
we'll find one more item as well. Okay,
so we bought the black demon mask for
799K and we sold it was for 650. It's
another master clue reward I believe.
Um, not many trade of these, but we'll
put an offer in for a couple of these
and just see how it goes. We'll do 10
and uh yeah, we'll get one more item at
least. And we are also going to try this
other mask as well. We just bought it
for 500k. It's called the old demon mask
and uh we sold it for 300k. Uh, so
that's pretty good. Assuming we can buy
a couple of these at least. Uh, put an
offer in for 3001k and 10 and then we'll
come back when we actually sell some of
the stuff. Okay, we are back and we have
finally sold the samurai equipment um
for a decent profit. So, we'll go
through it quickly here. So, the samurai
boots we ended up getting a 27k margin
on and we did get 19 of the boots giving
us 513k.
The samurai greaves we actually got a
800 and or sorry 88k margin on and we
got 10 of those giving us actually about
900k in profit which is quite good. The
hill giant clubs we only managed to get
three of but we did get about 175k
profit on each one given us 530k on that
item and the old demon mask we only got
one of and sold it back so we just kind
of broke even.
And in conclusion, we also have the uh
black mask selling off. So, we'll
calculate that in a little bit. And
yeah, we'll get a new item going. So,
the hill giant club still has about a
130k margin on it. Uh, which is pretty
good. The only reason I ended up getting
three last time is I got undercut pretty
quickly. So, we'll go ahead and do 10
quantity. Uh, sorry, six quantity, I
guess. And, um,
yeah, I don't know. Yeah, we'll just do
six for now. So, we're just checking the
chaos top here. Bought it for almost
elite actually. 1338k
and we sold it for 1220.
That's pretty decent. I think we'll do a
bit of the elder chaos hop top hood
hood. The hood, sorry. And we'll put in
Hoffin for about 1221k. And uh
I think we're just going to use the rest
of our money here. So, we'll do 14
roughly. Maybe 13. We can't afford 14.
And yeah, we'll come back when the stuff
has sold.
Okay, so we had to actually buy a bond
and we bought for 3.2 mil. So, we'll
take that into factor when we calculate
our total amount this episode, but we
did pretty decent on the flips. Once
again, the uh hill giant clubs, we got
131k on each club, and six of them gives
us about 786k in profit. The Elder Chaos
Hood, we didn't make much on, maybe 40K.
But the Black Demon Mask, we did finally
sell off for 150k profit. And we got
five masks, giving up about 740k.
So quite good. We're very consistently
getting close to a mill in profit per
flip. So it's getting much quicker. And
uh yeah, let's go see what else we can
do. So one item we've kind of been
thinking of doing for a while is a piece
of this Anku set. Now it's much more
expensive than any of the items I've
ever done. I think the cheapest one and
probably the one we're going to do is
the Anku socks that still runs around
six to 7 mil.
So,
I'm a little undecided if I'm going to
actually check the margin or just guess.
Um because it is very expensive. It
could be 500, 600, even maybe a mill to
check it. Um but at the same time, this
is so little of these traded. If I don't
have the right price, I could be waiting
days.
Um
ah
okay, [__] it. We're going to check the
margin. So we bought it for 7.745K.
And what are we going to be able to sell
it for?
Oh my god. Can't even sell it for 7 mil.
So it has pretty much a 1 mil margin.
Something close to that anyway. Put in
for 6 mil.
Okay, we sold it for 7 6.8K. 6.8 mil,
sorry. So that is a 1 mil profit per
item bought. So we just lost a mill
check in it, but uh we'll go ahead and
buy as many as we can afford right now.
Uh which is going to be five. And
hopefully we buy some and we'll come
back when uh they've sold. Well, would
you look at that? They have all sold and
we sold them all for 770K.
That is giving us a 96k
margin on each piece we bought. and we
bought five. Now, I'm not going to count
five because it did cost us 1 mil to
check it. But even at four in the
profit, it gives us about 3.6 mil from
that flip, which is awesome. And that's
going to leave us about 39 mil for now.
Actually, closer to 40 mil. So, I think
that's where we're going to end the
episode, guys. I hope you enjoyed. We
started about 35 mil. We bought a M bond
for 3 mil and yet we are finishing the
episode at about a 5 mil profit. So that
means we made between eight and 9 mil
this episode. Four of that pretty much
being in just a single item, a single
flip. So we are definitely going to try
these again next week. Let's see how
much progress we can make. And yeah, I
will see you guys in episode 22.
[Music]